[Music]
hey what's up i'm kbhd here and you
might not know this but the oneplus 10
pros out
kinda
oneplus has been on a kind of a weird
trajectory lately and i've kind of
already talked about it but this is the
latest
weirdest step so i say it's kinda out
because well you're watching this video
on youtube which is not in china but
this phone is officially landed and
launched only in china so it's not out
where you're watching this but we'll
likely see an international launch at
some point this year for this phone so i
was able to get my hands on this one
thanks to our friends at dbrand but if
you wanted to get one you have to import
it from a site like 28 mobile or
something like that but even so the
software that this phone is running is
not the oxygen os that oneplus fans have
come to know and love in many regions so
basically this phone might have a
oneplus box and the oneplus logo and a
oneplus red cable but this oneplus 10
pro is more like an oppo phone than ever
before now you might have seen all the
specs and teasers and stuff about this
phone as they were coming up to their
launch and i'll get to all that in a
second but the biggest thing to note
really is that this phone this one right
here is literally running oppo software
so it has color os the same color os
that an oppo phone would have this is
color os 12.1 so the oxygen os that's
been so important to oneplus for years
that i've really liked in the past is
not here so we've got some oppo built
stock apps and it's got a bunch of
incomplete menus that don't have english
translations there's a bunch of
pre-installed chinese apps that can't be
disabled this is clearly not meant to be
exported to other regions
the default browser's pretty rough i
mean it's it's mostly fine and it does
have a lot of customization features i
think the wallpaper color picker is
super cool and i've gotten google apps
to work other than the assistant so i
can make my way around but it's not
ideal so sort of overhanging all of this
is okay will this phone have oxygen os
or not when it eventually probably
launches internationally
i don't know it's unconfirmed we don't
have an answer yet and even though it's
not perfect and honestly oxygen os is
more like color os than ever before in
its latest version i still am kind of
hoping for it because it's more complete
anyway the one thing that will be the
same no matter where you get this phone
in any region is this new design this
slightly controversial new design
it's kind of a mixed bag for me i like
parts of it i don't like some other
parts of it so there's always a
difference between seeing it in the
renders and the teasers versus actually
holding it and filling it in person and
i gotta say in person it's a pretty
solid design it's a nice size roughly
the same size as last year's oneplus 9
pro big but not too big it's got the
same smooth satin black finish in this
volcanic black color and the other
version is this sort of emerald green
type of satin finish and it's still got
all the classic oneplus shapes and cues
the centered logo on the middle of the
back the speaker and sim card tray at
the bottom the alert slider which has
just moved up a little bit higher on the
phone really the biggest change with
this new design is the camera layout so
clearly there's a bit of inspiration
from what samsung did with the s21
series a little bit of a copy my
homework but don't make it too obvious
going on here but i do still like
samsung's version more because it still
feels more intentional one because it
goes all the way up to the corner and it
feels like a more integrated part of the
design
and two because of this seam here so
oneplus has this awesome satin black and
the whole back and all the rails around
the phone are satin but then it cuts at
this seam to do a glossy camera array
and i know we've done the stovetop joke
about other phones before but i mean
this one this one looks more like a
stovetop than any i've ever seen it's
actually only three cameras though the
fourth in the corner is a bi-color led
flash with some text in the middle that
says p2d50t now if you're wondering what
p2d50t
actually stands for i asked oneplus
because i mean there's not a whole lot
of other text on the phone why did they
put this here apparently p stands for
phone
2d stands for second generation
hasselblad mobile camera system
50t
stands for 50 megapixel triple camera
setup
so
so p2d 50t
just printed
okay i don't see a specific ip rating
anywhere for this phone but it does have
the rubber seals around things like the
sim card tray which the ip68 certified
oneplus 9 pro also had so i'm thinking
it'll also survive normal splashes and
stuff but the only other update on the
outside is a small one it's the new
display same size at 6.7 inches with the
top left corner selfie camera cut out
and an optical fingerprint sensor that's
nicely higher up on the phone i was
wondering why last year's is so low and
i never really got an answer but this
one isn't a nicer spot for sure anyway
it's the same resolution 1440p
same max frame rate 120 hertz but this
is an ltpo2 panel meaning it can
modulate all the way down to 1 hertz
instead of 10 hertz so it can save even
more power than earlier ldpo displays
definitely looking forward to seeing
pretty much every high-end phone make
this same upgrade this year then inside
this phone does have pretty much all the
high-end specs that you'd expect from
a oneplus flagship phone now this isn't
the full review i'm not daily driving
this phone because half the software is
in chinese and it's kind of hard for me
to do that but this does give us a
pretty good idea of how it'll perform
and i mean with high-end specs
there aren't really any surprises here
it's got the snapdragon 8 gen 1 chipset
new naming scheme for the new generation
of four nanometer chips first phone i've
tested with it uh it's it's very similar
in performance to the snapdragon triple
eight with a bump in the gpu department
and most significantly better ai and ml
performance so you can imagine as the
highest end non-custom silicon chip you
can get in a phone combined with the
high refresh rate display ufs 3.1
storage lpddr5 ram it's going to perform
very well there's even a ram extender
feature that you can use so you can sort
of carve out some of that fast storage
to act like extra ram if you want to
basically i have thought for a few years
actually that oppo's color os has some
of the better animations of any android
skin and that's still true so things are
very smooth and responsive here across
the board and then the bonus is some
slightly better gaming performance and a
new image signal processor which should
improve the cameras which speaking of
the cameras
how are they right this is uh this is a
new
i mean the design very much highlights
these new cameras and the hasselblad
logo is right there so does it deliver
well basically the camera housing might
have gotten a redesign but the actual
camera system is almost the same as last
year so it's the same 48 megapixel main
camera the same 8 megapixel 3.3 x
telephoto camera as last year and a new
150 degree ultra wide so the new
second generation hasselblad mobile
camera system is
as far as we can tell the same mobile
camera system plus a new ultrawide
unclear if there's any new lenses or
anything going into the hardware but
that's what we get okay got it so my
initial impressions shooting with it are
the actual quality of the images is
still pretty good i mean we know what
this main camera is capable of which is
some pretty nice shots and daytime
lighting plus the larger sensor giving
real shallow depth of field plus a
little fringing with some close-up
subjects but that's not a surprise here
but whatever's in focus in the middle of
the frame or near the middle of the
frame gets pretty good detail and
sharpness and it looks fine i was
looking for some new like color science
maybe maybe the second generation
hasselblad stuff has more to do with
image processing
and colors in dynamic range i think are
still good not too over processed but
nothing dramatically better than
expected here the colors from the ultra
wide are definitely a bit different from
the primary camera and it's definitely
not as sharp but that can improve a bit
with software updates i just found the
shutter speed not very fast so you got
to really hold still and take photos of
still subjects but hey not all subjects
stay still so in my initial testing like
object photos and still scenes are no
problem but people and pets get a little
more blurred sometimes especially in
lower light the selfie camera though is
actually new 32 megapixels not super
wide and not really noteworthy in the
quality department in my opinion but hey
y'all want to know about the selfie
camera so there you go this hasselblad
partnership is more than just image
quality though it's also about features
and so the new ultrawide is a new
feature and you know if you just open
the camera and just switch to the
ultrawide it'll look exactly the same as
any other but
buried in the settings there is a 150
degree ultra wide mode that lets you get
really really wide and take advantage of
that new sensor and lenses it does a
pretty good job not distorting things
too much considering how wide it is
which is very impressive at this angle
so even if the photos aren't super sharp
they're still unique and pretty
impressive and then you can hit this
button and get in that full on all the
way fisheye circle image mode to capture
everything no video capture in this mode
i think that would have been cool like
sort of reminiscent of old skate videos
but yeah this is pretty sweet there's
also the hasselblad x-pan mode to shoot
in that 65 by 24 aspect ratio
reminiscent of a classic hasselblad
camera and there's a new pro mode with
some raw formats which is great and a
new long exposure mode cool but overall
as you can tell you know not a huge
difference in the camera department
basically if you weren't sold on last
year's phone then this one's not going
to change your mind but i think i can
wrap this up with one thing that did
improve dramatically and that is the
battery so without getting much thicker
or bigger this phone is now packing a 5
000 milliamp hour battery and upgrades
to 80 watt wired charging plus 50 watt
wireless charging which is sick so
usually you get you know a huge battery
but not so fast charging or a
medium-sized battery but with ultra fast
charging it's sort of like pick and
choose this is really impressive this is
basically combining the best of both
worlds so from a low battery you can add
about 60 charge in 15 minutes which on
such a big battery can last you an
entire new day and even if you don't
have a heavy day of use you know i
haven't really used this phone for very
long but you can already tell this
bigger battery combined with the ltpo2
display is going to reward lighter usage
days with a much longer screen on time i
feel like there's something different
about this charger though i mean this is
the old one this it's a little more
squared off
it's still got the red cable it's still
the same size oh right
uh it's an oppo charger so as part of
the the melting of the oppo and
oneplus brands the oppo vacation of
oneplus as we've talked about yeah they
switched literally to a supervooc
charger it says it on their site that's
the name of oppo's fast charging tech uh
it's no longer a warp charger that
oneplus used to ship with everything now
honestly the name of the charging tech
doesn't really bother me that much but
the most annoying part is it's switched
back to usb-a
this is a usb-a charger now all of these
warp chargers were usb-c
and so now we've gone back so i can't
use usb-c to usb-c cables anymore i have
to use this cable so this is annoyingly
backwards i mean the fact that the phone
does come with the charger in the box is
sadly like bonus points for this phone
that's what you have to do when 80 watt
charging is one of your features is
nobody has an 80 watt charger so you
have to throw it in but yeah
here you go it's a usba charger also if
you want to do that 50 watt air vook
wireless charging that is a separate
extra oppo wireless charger still a
super impressive battery though and you
know what else is super impressive
channel sponsor cash app so cash app is
impressive not just because it's the
best way to send spend and save money
but also it comes with a debit card that
you can fully customize and then cash
app will laser print and mail it to you
whatever your fancy design and the card
comes with free discounts to places you
love called boosts so you're definitely
going to want to check out cash app if
you haven't already the link is below
you can use code marquez for 15
and 10 dollars will go to girls who code
appreciate your cash app so almost
exactly one year ago today it was
january last year i did a what happened
to oneplus video
and i was basically talking i'll link it
below it's just talking about how they
went from a very enthusiast focused
company to a very
normal company making
normal phones it didn't really stand out
in quite the same way
and this is their most
normal phone yet now that doesn't mean
it's a bad phone
at all it's actually quite good and you
know lots of the stuff that i've always
liked about oneplus phones are still
here it's got the fast and smooth stuff
it's got the high refresh rate display
great performance and high-end specs
really really fast charging on a massive
new battery and of course decent cameras
still got the alert slider great haptics
so it's got a lot of good stuff but we
don't have an international launch so
therefore we don't have a real price for
this phone yet so i gotta withhold any
of my official review type judgment
until then like if it ends up being
seven eight nine hundred dollars which
is probably about where it'll land
i could see it being pretty reasonable
but anything higher than that it's
competing with the big dogs and i think
anything lower than that would be a
surprise so
let me know would you want a phone like
this the oneplus 10 pro
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace